en el aniversario décimo primero del
programa de acción diferida daca el
presidente biden insistió en los
llamados al congreso para lograr
otorgarle un camino a la legalidad a los
jóvenes soñadores que hacen parte del
programa daca un programa Que Barack
Obama otorgó en su momento para la
protección contra la deportación a
aquellos que llegaron como menores de
edad a Estados Unidos el programa que
hoy tiene más de 800.000 jóvenes
soñadores a los que se les concedió esta
protección y la capacidad de trabajar en
Estados Unidos ha estado congelado desde
el 2021 por problemas legales ese año un
tribunal de apelaciones confirmó una
decisión que bloqueaba nuevas
inscripciones de jóvenes en el programa
además Trump intentó poner fin a daca en
su momento pero fue bloqueado por la
Corte Suprema once años después
soñadores activistas siguen presionando
para la aprobación de la ley Dream que
se ha presentado Ya varias veces al
congreso y que le otorgaría un camino
hacia la ciudadanía para los jóvenes
soñadores sin embargo es casi seguro que
en una cámara de representante es de
mayoría republicana este impulso fracase